on le drapeau finlandais hissé au siège
de l'OTAN à Bruxelles c'est historique
après trop décennies de noms alignement
militaire à la Finlande devient
officiellement le 31e est à membre de
l'Alliance atlantique l'initiative du
Parti communiste il marche vers l'Elysée
le cortège républicain comme il
l'appelle vous les rencontrez le
président de la République
qui paraissait trop longtemps
d'autres ont préféré aller discuter avec
Elisabeth borne et donc de répondre à
son invitation à Matignon et tant mieux
et c'est leur choix je le respecte on a
été très très rapide on lui a dit qu'il
n'y aurait pas de paix sans retrait et
quand je dis ça c'est pas une menace de
ma part ce sont les faits c'est la terre
esprit du pays je pense que on est dans
une impasse est-ce constitutionnel
d'utiliser l'ensemble des outils en te
parlementaire de la 5ème république
c'est-à-dire à la fois le 47 ans le 44 3
pour le vote bloqué au Sénat le 49.3 et
j'en passe donc c'est c'est ça la
question qui va être posée l'hostilité à
la réforme peut par ailleurs conduire à
certaines extrémités regardez cette
fresque qui fait polémique on y voit le
président grimé c'est l'ingénieur c'est
lui qui est aux manettes et dans la
mesure où le romanètes nous allons voir
celui qui est aux manettes le graffeur
Let's Go est l'auteur de cette fresque à
Avignon il n'en est pas à son coup
puisqu'il sera jugé en septembre
prochain pour une autre caricature du
président de la République et il y en a
qui ont fait le choix d'aller nulle part
aussi bah ils sont nulle part vous vous
parlez avec personne mais nous c'est
pardon je parle avec vous déjà on fait
de la politique
elle invite des groupes pour dire voilà
je cherche à élargir ma majorité je ne
vais pas lui faire perdre de temps je
suis défavorable avec ce gouvernement
madame la Première ministre vous voulez
tourner la page sortir le pays du chaos
social et démocratique dans lequel
l'obstination d'un président boukerisait
la plongée dans le des mois la seule et
surizona pacifique et démocratique mais
heureux madame la députée il ne fait pas
profil bas face aux centaines de caméras
qu'il attendent à New York bien au
contraire un salut fier à l'entrée de la
tour qui porte son nom sur la 5e Avenue
madame la député vous vous posez comme
porte-parole des quatre groupes de
gauche de cette émission pour dire que
vous ne participerez à rien
il n'y a justement rien de nouveau dans
votre interpellation vous ne participez
à rien vous ne proposez rien il est
poursuivi pour avoir acheté le silence
de cette actrice porno stormy Daniel en
2016 avec l'argent de sa campagne vous
espériez beaucoup ça devait bien se
passer mais voilà la poussière mis sous
le tapis remonte à la figure voilà c'est
votre bilan celui d'Emmanuel Macron
monsieur le ministre quelle plante de
bataille pour sauver Marseille sur le
trafic de drogue selon la chaîne
américaine CNN d'une trentaine de chefs
d'accusation ont été retenus contre lui
il devrait plaider non coupable je
reconnais votre partie vous ne loupez
jamais un rendez-vous cynique avec le
malheur et pendant ce temps-là
voyez-vous le ministre de l'Intérieur
est moi-même nous agissons et nous avons
mis en place un plan Marshall à
Marseille la une qui utilise pour parler
de ça pour traiter de l'information est
une vie photo
la poitrine exposée encore moins avec le
tatouage qui est très drôle soit dit en
passant 49-3 je fais un lien direct
entre les trafiquants et les
consommateurs le confort festif et bien
ça donne aussi des règlements de comptes
et tous ceux qui consomment le petit
pétard le samedi soir
devrait s'en souvenir l'équipage de la
mission Artémis 2 a été dévoilé par la
NASA noter la présence d'un
afro-américain Victor Glover et d'une
femme un Cristina amocoke qui ont tous
deux déjà voyagé dans l'espace la NASA
est dans la droite ligne de sa promesse
d'envoyer la première femme et la
première personne de couleur sur la lune
régulièrement vous venez nous voir en
disant ah c'est fini la nups ah ça a
pété la nups ah ça va pas la nups ça
continue non mais attendez il y a des
hauts il y a des bas vous connaissez une
famille dans lesquels ça se déchire pas
de temps en temps et ben on se déchire
de temps en temps ça arrive un homme qui
tue une laverie en Espagne et chape de
justesse à un accident aussi
spectaculaire qu’improbable
la police évoque la présence dans le
séchoir d'un aérosol comme celui-ci
utilisé pour recharger les briquets